00:00:35
WE'LL HEAR ARGUMENT NUMBER 18, ROE AGAINST
WADE. MRS. READINGTON, YOU MAY PROCEED WHEREVER
YOU ARE
00:01:05
Unidentified Speaker
READY. >> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE AND MAY IT PLEASE
THE COURT, THE INSTANT CASE IS A DIRECT APPEAL
FROM A DECISION OF THE UNITED STATES DISTRICT
COURT FOR...
00:01:38
Unidentified Speaker
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO DETERMINE TO CONTINUE OR
TERMINATE A PREGNANCY. ALTHOUGH THE COURT
GRANTED DECLARATORY RELIEF, THEY DENIED THE
REQUEST FOR INJUNCTIVE...
00:03:19
Unidentified Speaker
WORKING WITH THE STATUTE WHICH PROVIDED THAT
AN ABORTION COULD BE PERFORMED FOR REASONS
OF HEALTH OR LIFE. OUR TEXAS STATUTE PROVIDES
AN ABORTION
00:03:29
Unidentified Speaker
ONLY WHERE IT IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF SAVING
THE LIFE OF THE WOMAN.
00:03:34
Unidentified Speaker
SINCE THAT ADDITION WAS RENDERED,
00:03:37
Unidentified Speaker
THE TEXAS COURT OF CRIMINAL APPEALS, WHICH
IS OUR HIGHEST COURT OF JURISDICTION, HAS
HELD THAT THE TEXAS LAW IS NOT VAGUE BUT SAYING
IT IS MORE DEFINITE...
00:07:44
Unidentified Speaker
ARE A GOOD MANY THRESHOLD QUESTIONS, ARE THERE
NOT, OF -- >> YES, YOUR HONOR, THERE ARE.
>> JURISDICTION. >> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT,
OF COURSE, TO...
00:07:53
Unidentified Speaker
COURT THAT IN
00:07:54
Unidentified Speaker
MY READING OF
00:07:58
Unidentified Speaker
YOUNGER VS HARRISON
00:08:00
Unidentified Speaker
ALL THE COURT WAS CONCERNED ABOUT IN THOSE
CASES WAS THIZATION WHERE THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO INTERFERE WITH A PENDING STATE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION. IN...
00:08:09
Unidentified Speaker
POINTED OUT,
00:08:10
Unidentified Speaker
THE ORIGINAL
00:08:11
Unidentified Speaker
PARTIES TO THIS MATTER ARE WOMEN, AND IN ONE
CASE THE HUSBAND. THE WOMEN, CERTAINLY, ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO PROSECUTION IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS. THEY ARE...
00:08:57
Unidentified Speaker
EVEN IN THAT SITUATION AND THAT IN FACT SHE
IS THE VICTIM OF OUR LAW. SHE CAN -- THERE
IS NO DECLARATORY RELIEF AVAILABLE
00:09:04
Unidentified Speaker
FOR THESE PLAINTIFFS. THEIR ONLY FORUM WAS
THE FEDERAL COURT, AND IT WAS TO THOSE COURTS
THAT THEY TURNED. >> YOUR THREE PLAINTIFFS
REAR, REPRESENTING...
00:09:32
Unidentified Speaker
AND THEN THIRD IS A PHYSICIAN -- >>
00:09:34
Unidentified Speaker
YES. >> WHO IS UNDER INDICTMENT, OR WAS
00:09:36
Unidentified Speaker
AT THE TIME OF THIS COMPLAINT. >> THE PHYSICIAN
INTERVENED AFTER THE ORDER
00:09:40
Unidentified Speaker
WAS ENTERED GRANTING JANE ROE A THREE-JUDGE
00:09:44
Unidentified Speaker
COURT AND HE INTERVENED AGAIN, ASKING ONLY
THAT FUTURE PROSECUTION UNDER THE LAW BE ENJOINED.
HE DID NOT ASK ANY RELIEF OF THE COURT RELATING
TO HIS
00:09:54
Unidentified Speaker
PENDING STATE CRIMINAL
00:09:55
Unidentified Speaker
PROSECUTION. HE DID SPECIFICALLY, IN HIS
00:09:58
Unidentified Speaker
COMPLAINT, RESERVE THE RIGHT TO ASK FOR FUTURE
RELIEF, BUT THAT WAS NEVER DONE, AND CERTAINLY
IN THE FUTURE IF HE WAS ASKED FOR RELIEF THE
COURT WOULD...
00:12:50
Unidentified Speaker
CRIMINAL. AND EVEN THERE ARE SOME CASES WHICH
INDICATE THAT OUR STATE SUPREME COURT WOULD
NOT
00:12:56
Unidentified Speaker
HAVE THE ABILITY TO INDAMUS ANY OF THE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION OFFICERS BECAUSE THE TEXAS COURT
OF CRIMINAL APPEALS HAS JURISDICTION AS TO
ALL CRIMINAL ...
00:14:48
Unidentified Speaker
IF THE PREGNANCY WOULD RESULT IN THE BIRTH
OF A
00:14:52
Unidentified Speaker
DEFORMED OR DEFECTIVE CHILD HE -- HE HAS NO
RELIEF
00:14:57
Unidentified Speaker
REGARDLESS OF THE PURPOSE OF -- SHE HAS NO
RELIEF. I THINK IT IS WITHOUT QUESTION THAT
PREGNANCY TO A WOMAN CAN COMPLETELY DISRUPT
HER LIFE, WHETHER...
00:18:41
Unidentified Speaker
BECAUSE OF COURSE, WE CANNOT HERE BE INVOLVED
SIMPLY WITH MATTERS OF POLICY, AS YOU KNOW.
>> YOUR HONOR, IN THE LOWER COURTS AS I'M
SURE YOU ARE AWARE...
00:19:09
Unidentified Speaker
SUBMITTED TO THE COURT AND DISTRIBUTED AMONG
COUNCIL ENTITLED THE PHOENIX OF ABORTIONAL
FREEDOM THAT AT THE TIME THE CONSTITUTION
WAS ADOPTED THERE...
00:20:48
Unidentified Speaker
COURT FOUND THE RIGHT TO RESIDE IN THE NINTH
AMENDMENT, WE POINTED OUR ATTENTION IN THE
BRIEF TO
00:20:54
Unidentified Speaker
THAT PARTICULAR ASPECT OF THE CONSTITUTION.
BUT I THINK WE WOULD NOT PRESUME -- I DO
00:21:04
Unidentified Speaker
FEEL THAT --
00:21:06
Unidentified Speaker
THAT INSOMUCH AS THE COURT SAID THAT THE NINTH
AMENDMENT APPLIED TO THE RIGHTS RESERVED TO
THE PEOPLE THAT THE NINTH AMENDMENT IS THE
APPROPRIATE PLACE...
00:22:27
Unidentified Speaker
HAVE RESERVED TO THE WOMAN AS BEING THE VICTIM
AND THEY HAVE NEVER REFERRED TO ANYONE ELSE
AS BEING
00:22:32
Unidentified Speaker
THE VICTIM. TIMES HAVE CERTAINLY CHANGED.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT IN
TEXAS SELF-ABORTION IS NO CRIME. THE WOMAN
IS GUILTY OF NO CRIME...
00:24:15
Unidentified Speaker
THE SITUATION IN WHICH THE CASE IS HANDLED.
CERTAINLY, I THINK AS A
00:24:20
Unidentified Speaker
PRACTICAL MATTER, THOUGH, MOST OF THE STATES
THAT DO HAVE SOME TIME LIMIT INDICATED STILL
PERMIT ABORTIONS BEYOND
00:24:27
Unidentified Speaker
THE TIME LIMIT FOR
00:24:29
Unidentified Speaker
SPECIFIED REASONS, USUALLY WHERE THE HEALTH
OF THE MOTHER IS INVOLVED. >> WHAT'S YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL POSITION THERE? >> AS TO A
TIME LIMIT? >> WHATEVER...
00:24:53
Unidentified Speaker
00:24:56
THAT IT IS THE
00:24:57
Unidentified Speaker
FREEDOM OF WITH THE WOMAN TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT TO CONTINUE A PREGNANCY. OBVIOUSLY
I HAVE A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TIME SAYING THE
STATE HAS NO INTEREST...
00:25:16
Unidentified Speaker
I GUESS BY PERSONS CONSIDERING THE ISSUE OUTSIDE
THE LEGAL CONTEXT. I THINK AS FAR AS THE STATE
-- >> DO YOU OR DON'T YOU SAY THAT THE CONSTITUTIONAL...
00:25:29
Unidentified Speaker
RIGHTS YOU INSIST
00:25:30
Unidentified Speaker
ON REACHES FROM THE TIME OF BIRTH OR -- >> THE
CONSTITUTION AS I READ IT AND AS
00:25:35
Unidentified Speaker
IS INTERPRETED AND
00:25:37
Unidentified Speaker
DOCUMENTS BY PROFESSOR MEANS ATTACHES PROTECTION
TO THE PERSON AT THE TIME OF BIRTH THOSE PERSONS
BORN ARE CITIZENS.
00:25:44
Unidentified Speaker
THE ENUMERATION CLAUSE. WE COUNT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE
00:25:47
Unidentified Speaker
BORN. THE CONSTITUTION, AS I SEE IT, GIVES
PROTECTION
00:25:50
Unidentified Speaker
TO PEOPLE AFTER
00:25:53
Unidentified Speaker
BIRTH. >> (INAUDIBLE) THE ISSUE HERE, I GUESS,
ON YOUR APPEAL IS WHETHER YOU ARE ENTITLED
TO INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. >> YES, YOUR HONOR.
>> ASSUMING THAT...
00:26:16
Unidentified Speaker
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF? THERE ARE DIFFERENT THINGS
(INAUDIBLE) >> YES, SIR. CERTAINLY IN YOUR
DISSENT YOU POINT OUT IN (INAUDIBLE)
00:26:24
Unidentified Speaker
DISSENTING OPINION -- >> THAT WAS A DEFENSE.
>> IT WAS
00:26:27
Unidentified Speaker
A DEFENSE, THAT THERE ARE DIFFERENT STANDARDS
WHICH APPLY TO THE DECLARATORY JUDGMENT AND
TO INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. >> I GUESS YOU SAID
THAT IN (INAUDIBLE)...
00:26:41
Unidentified Speaker
SAID FOLLOWING LICKLER VERSUS TUTOR,
00:26:46
Unidentified Speaker
THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
00:26:48
Unidentified Speaker
GRANTING DECLARATORY RELIEF DIFFERENT RULES
APPLIED TO INJUNCTIVE RELIEF BUT THE OPINIONS
OF THIS COURT HAS ESTABLISHED
00:26:55
Unidentified Speaker
WHETHER THERE IS GREAT AND IMMEDIATE THREAT
00:26:58
Unidentified Speaker
OF IRREPARRABLE INJURY WITH NO ADEQUATE REMEDY
IN STATE COURT THAT AN INJUNCTION IS STILL
PROPER AND IT IS OUR POSITION THAT THERE IS
GREAT AND IMMEDIATE...
00:27:30
Unidentified Speaker
HONOR. >> WHAT ABOUT
00:27:32
Unidentified Speaker
THE DOCTOR, WHERE A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION IS
ALREADY PENDING AGAINST HIM? >> THE DOCTOR,
AS I SAID, I WAS ASKING NO
00:27:40
Unidentified Speaker
RELIEF AS TO THE PENDING PROSECUTION, HE WAS
ONLY ASKING RELIEF AS TO THE FUTURE -- >>
00:27:44
Unidentified Speaker
NOT ASKING FOR DECLARATORY
00:27:46
Unidentified Speaker
JUDGMENT? >> YES, YOUR HONOR, HE JOINED IN
BOTH THE REQUEST FOR THE DECLARATORY JUDGMENT
-- >>
00:27:50
Unidentified Speaker
ISN'T YOUNGER
00:27:53
Unidentified Speaker
AND (INAUDIBLE) CASES COVER DECLARATORY JUDGMENT?
>> WHERE THERE
00:27:58
Unidentified Speaker
WERE PENDING -- SAMUELS VERSUS MICHAEL, AS
I READ IT, DID SAY THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A REQUEST
00:28:05
Unidentified Speaker
FOR DECLARATORY JUDGMENT, THERE
00:28:07
Unidentified Speaker
WOULD BE AN EFFECT ON A PENDING CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
>> WAS ONE PENDING -- >> THERE WAS ONE PENDING
WHEN THIS
00:28:13
Unidentified Speaker
ACTION WAS BROUGHT. AGAINST DR.
00:28:18
Unidentified Speaker
HALFORD. HOWEVER, IN THIS CASE, WE SUBMIT
THAT IF THERE IS TO BE ANY MEANING TO THE
FEDERAL COURTS AS THE SUPREME ARBITERS OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS...
00:28:30
Unidentified Speaker
TO ACT, AT LEAST IN
00:28:32
Unidentified Speaker
SOME FORM, WHEN THERE ARE PENDING CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS, NOT PARTICULARLY AGAINST THE
PERSON INVOLVED IN THE PROSECUTIONS BUT OTHER
-- >> (INAUDIBLE)...
00:29:02
Unidentified Speaker
THAT? >> I'M SUGGESTING THAT IN IN CASE, THE
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR BROUGHT A DECLARATORY
ACTION HAVING NOTHING TO DO WITH THE PENDING
STATE CRIMINAL PROSECUTION....
00:29:17
Unidentified Speaker
DOCTOR CERTAINLY SHOULDN'T BE SUFFICIENT -- >> WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DOCTOR'S
00:29:20
Unidentified Speaker
CASE. >> RIGHT. AND BECAUSE THE DOCTOR INTERVENED,
WHEN HE WAS ASKING
00:29:24
Unidentified Speaker
NO RELIEF AS TO THE PENDING STATE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION, THAT HAS INTERVENTION -- >> YOU
MEAN HE WAS ASKING NOTHING -- HE WAS ASKING
00:29:34
Unidentified Speaker
WHAT? AGAINST THE CONTINUEANCE OF THAT
00:29:36
Unidentified Speaker
PROGRESS? >> THAT'S RIGHT. >> DECLARATORY
JUDGMENT -- >> AS
00:29:39
Unidentified Speaker
TO FUTURE PROSECUTION. >>
00:29:40
Unidentified Speaker
EXCEPT THAT HE WANTED DECLARATORY JUDGMENT,
AS I UNDERSTAND IT. >> YES. >> THE UNDERLYING
STATUTE ON WHICH THE PROSECUTION WAS BROUGHT
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL....
00:29:50
Unidentified Speaker
THAT'S WHAT SAMUELS AND MICHAEL SAID HE DIDN'T
HAVE. >> ASK WHICH YOUR DISSENT SAID HE DIDN'T
HAVE. >>
00:29:57
Unidentified Speaker
00:29:58
I
00:29:59
Unidentified Speaker
REPEAT -- (INAUDIBLE) >>
00:30:00
Unidentified Speaker
OK. I THINK PERHAPS WE WOULD STRESS THAT
00:30:03
Unidentified Speaker
THERE ARE TWO SEPARATE
00:30:04
Unidentified Speaker
ACTIONS BEFORE THE COURT. FIRST, THAT OF THE
WOMEN. AND SECOND, THAT OF
00:30:09
Unidentified Speaker
THE DOCTOR. >> SO THAT EVEN THOUGH -- >> EVEN
THOUGH THE DOCTOR -- EVEN THOUGH
00:30:12
Unidentified Speaker
THE COURT MIGHT FIND THAT THE DOCTOR WAS AN
INAPPROPRIATE
00:30:15
Unidentified Speaker
PARTY FOR RELIEF IT CERTAINLY WOULD NOT AFFECT
00:30:19
Unidentified Speaker
THE ORIGINAL ACTION AS BROUGHT BY THE WOMEN.
>>
00:30:21
Unidentified Speaker
ALL RIGHT. I COME BACK AGAIN, IF WE'RE LEFT
ONLY WITH THE LADIES' ACTION, ARE YOU SUGGESTING
00:30:29
Unidentified Speaker
THAT
00:30:31
Unidentified Speaker
THE DECLARATORY RELIEF THEY ALREADY OBTAINED
IS NOT ENOUGH BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T HELP TERMINATE
THE PREGNANCY? >> BECAUSE THEY ARE STILL
00:30:41
Unidentified Speaker
SUBJECT TO THE IRREPARABLE INJURY AND HAD
NO STATE REMEDY. IF THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO CONTINUE
TO LITIGATE THEIR INTEREST IN THIS SITUATION,
ANYTIME THERE...
00:30:59
Unidentified Speaker
STATE COURT ON APPEAL -- OR IT WILL BE APPEALED
HERE, I THINK, AND CERTAINLY IF THEY CANNOT
LITIGATE THEIR INTERESTS WHILE THERE IS PROSECUTION
PENDING...
00:31:36
Unidentified Speaker
RIGHTS BUT THE RIGHTS OF HIS PATIENTS AND
THOSE SAME PATIENTS ARE SUFFERING THE SAME
SORT OF IRREPARABLE INJURY THAT THE ORIGINAL
00:31:44
Unidentified Speaker
PLAINTIFFS WERE SUFFERING. >> COULDN'T THE
DOCTOR RAISE THE SAME POINT IN THE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION? >> YES, YOUR HONOR, HE CAN. BUT
I -- I DON'T FEEL...
00:32:07
Unidentified Speaker
ISSUES HERE. THE ISSUE INVOLVING THE DOCTOR,
DA >> YES. >>
00:32:10
Unidentified Speaker
IS TO LITIGATE EVERYTHING HE'S NOW LITIGATING
IN THE STATE COURT. >> YES, YOUR HONOR, MY
POINT BEING THAT THESE WOMEN SHOULD NOT BE
COMPELLED TO LEAVE...
00:32:25
Unidentified Speaker
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION, ISN'T HE? YOU CAN COUNT
ON HIM TO DO THAT. >> WELL, I THINK THERE
ARE
00:32:29
Unidentified Speaker
DIFFERENT
00:32:30
Unidentified Speaker
INTERESTS INVOLVED. IN MOST
00:32:34
Unidentified Speaker
CRIMINAL PROSECUTIONS BRING UP OTHER PROBLEMS
-- >> "I DIDN'T DO IT" OR SOMETHING. >> OR
THE WITNESSES HAVE DISAPPEARED
00:32:42
Unidentified Speaker
OR -- >> HAS THIS DEFENSE EVER BEEN OPPOSED
IN A TEXAS CRIMINAL
00:32:48
Unidentified Speaker
CASE FOR CONSTITUTIONAL DEFENSE? >> YES, YOUR
HONOR, THERE IS ONE RECENT OPINION, THOMPSON
VERSUS THE STATE OF TEXAS WHICH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ATTEMPTED...
00:32:59
Unidentified Speaker
AND THE COURT REJECTED IT, IT WAS A DECISION
00:33:01
Unidentified Speaker
ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF AGO WHICH ORIGINATED
IN HOUSTON. A
00:33:05
Unidentified Speaker
DOCTOR THERE WAS INDITED ON A CHARGE OF -- INDICTED
ON A CHARGE OF
00:33:10
Unidentified Speaker
ABORTION. AT TRIAL HE USED ONLY AN ALIBI DEFENSE
BUT ON APPEAL HE DID RAISE THE SAME CONSTITUTIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT WE RAISED IN THE FEDERAL COURTS
--...
00:33:39
Unidentified Speaker
THE CHIEF
00:33:40
Unidentified Speaker
JUSTICE. >> SECOND THEY DID NOT DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE WAS A RIGHT TO PRIVACY BUT DID
HOLD THERE WAS A COMPEMMING INTEREST, SO IN
-- COMPELLING INTEREST...
00:33:59
Unidentified Speaker
TO THE FEDERAL COURT OPINION FROM WHICH WE
ARE
00:34:01
Unidentified Speaker
APPEALING. >> THAT CASE CAN BE (INAUDIBLE)
>> THEY HAVE FILED A MOTION FOR REHEARING
IN THE STATE COURT OF CRIMINAL APPEALS WHICH
WILL BE ARGUED TOMORROW....
00:34:12
Unidentified Speaker
UNLIKELY THAT THE COURT WOULD CHANGE ITS OPINION,
AND IT IS THE INTENTION
00:34:17
Unidentified Speaker
OF THOSE PARTIES TO APPEAL. >> DOES TEXAS
LAW, IN
00:34:22
Unidentified Speaker
OTHER AREAS OF THE LAW, GIVE RIGHTS
00:34:24
Unidentified Speaker
TO UNBORN CHILDREN IN THE AREAS OF TRUST,
ESTATES AND WILLS OR -- >> NO, YOUR HONOR,
ONLY IF THEY'RE BORN ALIVE. THE SUPREME COURT
OF TEXAS RECENTLY...
00:34:42
Unidentified Speaker
THE CONDITION THAT IT BE BORN ALIVE. THE SAME
IS TRUE OF OUR PROPERTY LAW. THE CHILD MUST
BE BORN ALIVE. AND I THINK THERE IS A
00:34:50
Unidentified Speaker
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THOSE CHILDREN WHICH ARE
ULTIMATELY BORN, AND I THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE
TO GIVE THEM RETROACTIVE RIGHTS, I THINK IT'S
A COMPLETELY...
00:35:25
Unidentified Speaker
THERE WAS NO CAUSE OF ACTION WHATSOEVER. >> FOR
THE MOTHER -- >> I'M SPEAKING, EXCUSE ME,
SOLELY FOR THE
00:35:33
Unidentified Speaker
FETUS, THAT THE FETUS HAD NO INDEPENDENT RIGHT,
THAT THE MOTHER -- >>
00:35:38
Unidentified Speaker
THE MOTHER RECOVERING FROM THE DEATH OF THE
CHILD -- >>
00:35:41
Unidentified Speaker
ONLY FOR HER INJURY. >> ONLY FOR HERS. DID
THAT INCLUDE ANYTHING WITH REGARD TO THE CHILD?
>> NO, YOUR HONOR.
00:35:49
Unidentified Speaker
THANK YOU. >> THANK YOU, MRS.
00:35:51
Unidentified Speaker
WEDDINGTON. MR. FLOYD. >> MR. CHIEF JUSTICE,
MAY IT PLEASE THE
00:35:59
Unidentified Speaker
COURT. IT'S AN OLD JOKE, BUT
00:36:02
Unidentified Speaker
WHEN A MAN ARGUES AGAINST TWO
00:36:04
Unidentified Speaker
BEAUTIFUL LADIES LIKE THIS THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE THE LAST
00:36:08
Unidentified Speaker
WORD. I --
00:36:11
Unidentified Speaker
BEFORE I PROCEED TO THE ORIGINAL ISSUE IN
THIS CASE,
00:36:16
Unidentified Speaker
WHICH WAS THE PROPRIETY OF THE TRIAL COURT
GRANT -- OR DENYING INJUNCTIVE RELIEF, I WOULD
LIKE TO BRING TO THE COURT'S ATTENTION SOME
MATTERS CONCERNING...
00:38:53
Unidentified Speaker
SAY THE ONLY THING THAT WOULD UPHOLD HER STANDING
OR ELIMINATE THE MOOTNESS
00:38:57
Unidentified Speaker
ISSUE WOULD BE WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS A CLASS
ACTION
00:39:00
Unidentified Speaker
ON HER PART. >> YES, YOUR HONOR. >> THE RECORD
THAT CAME UP TO THIS COURT CONTAINS THE AMENDED
00:39:13
Unidentified Speaker
PETITION OF JANE ROE. AN UNSIGNED ALIAS AFFIDAVIT.
AND THAT IS ALL. SHE
00:39:26
Unidentified Speaker
ALLEGES THAT SHE WAS PREGNANT ON
00:39:28
Unidentified Speaker
APRIL THE 20TH, 1970, WHICH IS SOME 21 MONTHS
AGO. NOW, I THINK THAT IT IS -- IT HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE APPELLANT'S COUNSEL THAT
SHE IS NO LONGER...
00:42:19
Unidentified Speaker
THEIR STATUTE HAD BEEN -- IT'S NOT TRUE HERE.
>> IT'S NOT WHAT WE CALL A
00:42:24
Unidentified Speaker
WHITE HORSE. >> I
00:42:35
Unidentified Speaker
UNDERSTAND. >> IN RESPECT TO THE CLASS ACTION
PORTION OF THIS, AND I SAY I HAVE NO AUTHORITY
TO SUPPORT THIS PROPOSITION, BUT IT WOULD
APPEAR
00:42:43
Unidentified Speaker
THAT IN ORDER FOR A CLASS ACTION TO CONTINUE
IF THERE BE ONE TO BEGIN WITH IS THAT ONE
PLAINTIFF MUST REMAIN OR ELSE
00:42:55
Unidentified Speaker
AN INTERVENOR,
00:42:56
Unidentified Speaker
OR SOMEONE TO BE A REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CLASS.
BECAUSE THIS IS THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF THE CLASS
ACTION. TO HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE IN COURT.
THE POSITION...
00:43:38
Unidentified Speaker
IF I MAY. >> OK. >> I DO NOT BELIEVE IT CAN
BE DONE. THERE ARE SITUATIONS IN WHICH, OF
COURSE, AS THE COURT KNOWS, NO REMEDY IS PROVIDED.
I THINK SHE...
00:43:55
Unidentified Speaker
SHE BECOMES PREGNANT. THAT IS THE TIME OF
THE CHOICE. IT'S LIKE,
00:44:00
Unidentified Speaker
MORE OR LESS, THE FIRST THREE OR FOUR
00:44:02
Unidentified Speaker
YEARS OF HER LIFE WE DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING
BUT ONCE A CHILD IS BORN THE WOMAN NO LONGER
HAS A CHOICE AND I THINK PREGNANCY MAY TERMINATE
THAT CHOICE...
00:44:33
Unidentified Speaker
ON MOVING. >> YOUR HONOR, APPELLANT IS UNDER
TWO ARGUMENTS CHARGED WITH THE OFFENSE OF
PERFORMING AN ABORTION. THERE ARE NO ALLEGATIONS
IN THE COMPLAINT...
00:44:53
Unidentified Speaker
APPELLANT HALFORD OR NONE IN HIS AFFIDAVIT
THAT THERE IS ANY BAD
00:44:58
Unidentified Speaker
FAITH PROSECUTION, BAD FAITH ARREST, HARASSMENT
OF HIM AT ALL TO BRING HIM WITHIN PROSKEY'S
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES. WE THINK THE CASES
OF YOUNGER VS...
00:46:54
Unidentified Speaker
CAN DENY INJINCHINGTIVE RELIEF. >> CERTAINLY
IF THE JUDGMENT ABOUT THE -- IF THE DECLARATORY
JUDGMENT WAS ERRONEOUS, IT WAS ALSO RIGHT
TO DENY AN INJUNCTION....
00:47:13
Unidentified Speaker
COURT, OF COURSE -- >> DIDN'T APPEAL. >> WE
COULD NOT TO THIS COURT, YOUR
00:47:19
Unidentified Speaker
HONOR, WE HAVE TO GO TO THE FIFTH CIRCUIT,
SO WE HAVE -- >> ARE YOU ATTEMPTING TO SUSTAIN
THE DENIAL OF AN INJUNCTION HERE ON THE GROUNDS
THAT THE
00:47:29
Unidentified Speaker
DECLARATORY JUDGMENT WAS IMPROPER? >> WE
00:47:31
Unidentified Speaker
ARE ASKING THE COURT --
00:47:34
Unidentified Speaker
REQUESTING THE COURT TO DO THIS.
00:47:36
Unidentified Speaker
IF THE COURT GETS INTO
00:47:37
Unidentified Speaker
THE MERITS OF INJUNCTIVE RELIEF, WHETHER OR
NOT IT WAS PROPER UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES,
00:47:43
Unidentified Speaker
THAT THIS COURT GO FORWARD AND CONTINUE THE
OTHER -- OR CONTINUE THE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
AND MAKE A DECISION OR NOT. >> CAN WE DO
00:47:53
Unidentified Speaker
THAT? YOU AND THE FIFTH CIRCUIT, BECAUSE WE
SAID YOU COULDN'T CROSS-APPEAL FROM THE DECLARATORY
JUDGMENT, YOU COULD ONLY CROSS-APPEAL FROM
THE GRANTING...
00:48:13
Unidentified Speaker
YOU'RE HERE. YOUR OPPONENT HAS BROUGHT A DIRECT
APPEAL HERE BECAUSE YOUR OPPONENT WAS DENIED
AN UNJUNCTION BY THE THREE-JUDGE DISTRICT
COURT. >> YES,...
00:48:23
Unidentified Speaker
A CROSS APPEAL HERE BECAUSE YOU WON
00:48:25
Unidentified Speaker
FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF SUCCESSFULLY RESISTING
THE INJUNCTION. >> YES, SIR. >> NOW THAT YOU
ARE HERE AS THE APPELLEE, YOU ARE ARGUING
THAT AN
00:48:34
Unidentified Speaker
INJUNCTION SHOULD NOT HAVE ISSUED AND PART
OF THAT JUDGMENT VERY LEGITIMATELY CAN BE
THAT ON THE MERITS THE COURT
00:48:41
Unidentified Speaker
WAS WRONG AND THAT IT SHOULDN'T HAVE
00:48:43
Unidentified Speaker
ISSUED A DECLARATORY JUDGMENT OR AN INJUNCTION.
>> YES, YOUR HONOR. >> IS THAT YOUR POSITION?
>>
00:48:50
Unidentified Speaker
YES.
00:48:51
Unidentified Speaker
NOW THE PROCEDURES IN THE FIFTH CIRCUIT HAVE
BEEN STAYED OR ABATED -- >> (INAUDIBLE) SAY
YOUR POSITION MAKES SENSE TO ME. (INAUDIBLE)
ON THE COURT OPPOSE...
00:49:08
Unidentified Speaker
WANT TO BE REPETITION,
00:49:09
Unidentified Speaker
BUT A MOTION
00:49:10
Unidentified Speaker
HAS BEEN FILED IN THE FIFTH CIRCUIT TO HOLD
THE APPEAL IN ABEYANCE UNTIL A DETERMINATION
BY THIS COURT. >> YOU
00:49:17
Unidentified Speaker
DIDN'T ASK -- HE DIDN'T FILE ANY MOTION HERE
ASKING US TO BRING YOUR APPEAL PENDING IN
THE FIFTH CIRCUIT HERE FOR A DECISION WITH
THIS APPEAL, DID...
00:49:28
Unidentified Speaker
IN OUR REPLY TO THE JURISDICTION AND IN OUR
BRIEF. WE HAVE PRESENTED IT IN THAT
00:49:38
Unidentified Speaker
MANNER. YOUR HONOR, WE FEEL THAT THIS COURT
CAN AND SHOULD CONSIDER ALL ISSUES,
00:49:45
Unidentified Speaker
AND UNDER THE STERLING AND FLORIDA LYMAN CAR
GROWERS AND CARTER CASES WHICH ARE CITED IN
THE BRIEFS OF THE PARTIES. >> (INAUDIBLE)
TEXAS INTEREST --...
00:50:20
Unidentified Speaker
THE COURT OF APPEALS DID NOT DECIDE THE ISSUE
OF PRIVACY. IT WAS NOT BEFORE THE COURT. OR
THE RIGHT OF CHOICE ISSUE. THE STATE -- THE
STATE COURT,
00:50:31
Unidentified Speaker
THE COURT OF CRIMINAL APPEALS HELD THAT THE
STATE HAD A COMPELLING INTEREST BECAUSE OF
THE PROTECTION OF FETAL LIFE. OF FETAL LIFE.
PROTECTION. THEY...
00:51:26
Unidentified Speaker
HUMAN BEING? I DON'T KNOW, EXCEPT THAT I WILL
SAY THIS. AS MEDICAL
00:51:33
Unidentified Speaker
SCIENCE PROGRESSES, MAYBE THE LAW WILL PROGRESS
ALONG WITH IT. MAYBE AT ONE TIME IT COULD
BE POSSIBLY, I SUPPOSE, THAT IT COULD BE PASSED.
WHETHER OR...
00:52:04
Unidentified Speaker
COVERS THE ENTIRE PERIOD OF PREGNANCY. >> YES,
IT DOES, MR. JUSTICE,
00:52:10
Unidentified Speaker
YES, SIR. >> MR. FLOYD, DOES THAT -- I DON'T
FIND THAT (INAUDIBLE) I GATHER YOU SAID IT
HAS BEEN DECIDED RECENTLY. >>
00:52:18
Unidentified Speaker
MR.
00:52:19
Unidentified Speaker
JUSTICE, THIS CASE IS
00:52:20
Unidentified Speaker
JUST A RECENT CASE. >>
00:52:22
Unidentified Speaker
DO YOU HAVE A CITATION? >> IT
00:52:24
Unidentified Speaker
IS NOT IN THE REPORTER SYSTEM YET. >> ARE
YOU GOING TO PROVIDE US WITH
00:52:29
Unidentified Speaker
A TRANSCRIPT? >> I WILL BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THE COURT WITH COPIES OF
00:52:33
Unidentified Speaker
THAT. THIS IS NUMBER
00:52:39
Unidentified Speaker
00:52:42
44, 070, C.W. THOMPSON VERSUS
00:52:45
Unidentified Speaker
THE STATE OF
00:52:48
Unidentified Speaker
00:52:50
TEXAS. THE OPINION WAS DELIVERED ON NOVEMBER
THE 2ND, 1971. I WOULD BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
THE COURT WITH THIS COPY IF THE COURT SO DESIRES.
>> THAT'S...
00:53:32
Unidentified Speaker
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE THOMPSON CASE DECIDED
00:53:36
Unidentified Speaker
A HUGE CASE IN REGARD TO VAGUENESS
00:53:38
Unidentified Speaker
AND SAID THAT IT WAS CONTROLLING THE ISSUES,
AND
00:53:43
Unidentified Speaker
AS I RECALL,
00:53:45
Unidentified Speaker
DR. THOMPSON RAISED THE ISSUE OF HOW CAN YOU
FIND ME GUILTY OF MURDER -- I MEAN, OF
00:53:53
Unidentified Speaker
ABORTION IF YOU MAKE NO DETERMINATION THAT
THE FETUS IS ALIVE AT THE TIME I PERFORMED
THIS, IN EFFECT, IS WHAT HE'S SAYING. HE NEVER
ADMITTED DOING...
00:54:36
Unidentified Speaker
I THINK YOU ALSO SAID THAT WAS PERHAPS NOT
ITS ORIGINAL PURPOSE. >> WELL, I'M NOT SURE
OF THAT. >> IT MAY BE RATHER IMPORTANT. IN
A CONSTITUTIONAL CASE...
00:55:03
Unidentified Speaker
BE THE SAME IN
00:55:05
Unidentified Speaker
THIS RESPECT. THERE HAVE BEEN STATISTICS FURNISHED
TO THIS COURT IN VARIOUS BRIEFS FROM VARIOUS
GROUPS AND FROM MEDICAL
00:55:19
Unidentified Speaker
SOCIETIES OF DIFFERENT GROUPS OF PHYSICIANS
AND GYNECOLOGISTS OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE, THESE
STATISTICS HAVE NOT SHOWN ME, FOR INSTANCE
-- FOR EXAMPLE,...
00:56:28
Unidentified Speaker
LEGISLATION. >> I AM -- AND THIS IS JUST FROM
MY -- I SPEAK PERSONALLY, IF I MAY, I WOULD
THINK THAT EVEN WHEN THIS STATUTE WAS FIRST
PASSED THERE WAS...
00:56:50
Unidentified Speaker
1900, 1907, SOMEWHERE IN THERE. >> IT GOES
BACK -- >> IT GOES BACK MANY -- >> 19TH CENTURY.
>> BEFORE THAT THERE WERE NO CRIMINAL ABORTION
LAWS IN...
00:57:01
Unidentified Speaker
I KNOW, NO. I THINK THIS WAS MAYBE SET OUT
IN SOME
00:57:05
Unidentified Speaker
OF THE BRIEFS. I -- >> IN ANY EVENT, MR. FLOYD,
APART FROM YOUR PERSONAL ATTITUDE THE COURT
00:57:12
Unidentified Speaker
IS OPEN ON THE INTENT OF THE STATUTE, IS
00:57:14
Unidentified Speaker
IT NOT? >> YES. YES. >>
00:57:16
Unidentified Speaker
I CAN'T SQUARE THAT MOST
00:57:18
Unidentified Speaker
RECENT PRONOUNSMENT WITH THE EARLIER DECISIONS
OF THE TEXAS COURT THAT REFER TO THE MOTHER
00:57:23
Unidentified Speaker
AS THE VICTIM. CAN YOU? >> WELL, AS I
00:57:29
Unidentified Speaker
SAY, YOUR HONOR, I DON'T THINK THE
00:57:34
Unidentified Speaker
COURTS HAVE COME TO
00:57:37
Unidentified Speaker
THE CONCLUSION THAT THE UNBORN HAS FULL JURISTIC
RIGHTS. NOT YET. MAYBE THEY WILL. I DON'T
KNOW. I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE 10-POINT.
>> IN THE...
00:57:52
Unidentified Speaker
PREGNANCY? >> SIR? >> IN THE FIRST FEW WEEKS
OF PREGNANCY? >> AT ANY TIME, MR. JUSTICE.
WE MAKE NO DISTINCTIONS. >> (INAUDIBLE) THERE
ARE NOT. >> WE...
00:58:11
Unidentified Speaker
THE MOMENT OF
00:58:13
Unidentified Speaker
IMPREGNATION. >> AND DO YOU HAVE ANY SCIENTIFIC
DATA TO
00:58:16
Unidentified Speaker
SUPPORT THAT? >> WELL, WE BEGIN, MR. JUSTICE,
00:58:21
Unidentified Speaker
IN OUR BRIEF WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE HUMAN
EMBRYO CARRYING
00:58:27
Unidentified Speaker
IT THROUGH TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE FETUS
00:58:30
Unidentified Speaker
FROM ABOUT 7-9 DAYS AFTER CONCEPTION. >>
00:58:34
Unidentified Speaker
WHAT ABOUT SIX DAYS? >> WE DON'T KNOW. >> BUT
THE
00:58:39
Unidentified Speaker
STATUTE (INAUDIBLE) ONE HOUR. >> I DON'T -- MR.
JUSTICE, THERE
ARE UNANSWERABLE QUESTIONS IN THIS FIELD.
THIS IS AN ARTLESS STATEMENT ON MY PART. >>...
00:58:54
Unidentified Speaker
QUESTION. THANK
00:58:56
Unidentified Speaker
YOU. >> WHEN DOES THE SOUL COME INTO THE UNBORN?
00:59:00
Unidentified Speaker
IF THE PERSON BELIEVES IN A SOUL? I DON'T
00:59:05
Unidentified Speaker
00:59:14
KNOW. I ASSUME THE
00:59:18
Unidentified Speaker
APPELLANTS NOW ARE OPERATING UNDER -- >> I
ASSUME THE APPELLANTS NOW ARE OPERATING UNDER
THE NINTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS. THERE ARE ALLEGATIONS
OF FIRST...
00:59:42
Unidentified Speaker
OF ANY RELIGIOUS GROUP. I SEE NO MERIT IN
THEIR CONTENTION THAT
IT COULD POSSIBLY BE UNDER FREEDOM OF SPEECH
OR PRESS -- IN FACT, THERE HAVE BEEN SOME...
01:02:03
Unidentified Speaker
THE UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION CONCERNING
01:02:08
Unidentified Speaker
BIRTH, CONTRACEPTION OR
01:02:15
Unidentified Speaker
ABORTION. THE APPELLEE DOES NOT DISAGREE WITH
THE APPELLANTS' STATEMENT THAT A WOMAN HAS
A CHOICE, BUT AS WE HAVE PREVIOUSLY
01:02:23
Unidentified Speaker
MENTIONED WE FEEL THAT THIS CHOICE IS LEFT
UP -- IS THE WOMAN'S PRIOR TO THE TIME THAT
SHE BECOMES PREGNANT. THIS IS
THE TIME OF
THE CHOICE. NOW,...
01:03:18
Unidentified Speaker
THE PROCEDURE -- AND
01:03:19
Unidentified Speaker
I'M -- NOW I'M TELLING THE COURT SOMETHING
THAT IS OUTSIDE
01:03:23
Unidentified Speaker
THE RECORD BUT I UNDERSTAND THE PROCEDURE
WHEN A WOMAN IS BROUGHT IN AFTER RAPE IS YOU
TRY TO STOP WHATEVER HAS OCCURRED IMMEDIATELY
BY THE PROPER
01:03:32
Unidentified Speaker
PROCEDURE IN THE HOSPITAL,
01:03:35
Unidentified Speaker
IMMEDIATELY SHE'S TAKEN THERE, IF SHE REPORTS
IT
01:03:39
Unidentified Speaker
IMMEDIATELY, BUT NO, THERE IS NOTHING, NO
STATUTE. AS I PREVIOUSLY INFORMED THE COURT,
THE STATISTICS -- OR
THE PEOPLE WHO PREPARE THE STATISTICS AND...
01:05:24
Unidentified Speaker
IS
01:05:27
Unidentified Speaker
SUBMITTED.